[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here
okay pausing on all the Galaxy fold hype
for just a second this is the Huawei P
30 Pro this is the phone I've been using
for weeks leading up to all the galaxy
fold stuff and might as well keep using
after it this is the phone that you've
either never heard of or you've heard
all about it and are probably wondering
if these cameras are worth the hype I
gotta say the p30 Pro is the best phone
not sold in the US that's just facts and
that's of course gonna hurt its
popularity here but if you're gonna get
one which you still can you should know
all about the rest of it too I mean what
people are really here for is the camera
and we'll get to that but the rest of
the phones pretty damn good too so the
easiest way to think about this phone is
it's an upgraded design of the p20 Pro
but with all the best features of the
mate 20 Pro so aesthetically you can
tell Huawei definitely knows they struck
gold with this really unique triple
color gradient look I'd bet money that
was their number one seller of the p20
Pro because now all of them have this
look so there's a red gradient one this
pearly white gradient when I seen on
videos and then this one here is my
personal favorite a sort of a green to
blue to purple aurora starburst kind of
thing ryan's me actually of one of those
classic windows wallpapers remember this
one with the fish just me okay but yet
no it stands out if you're about that
psychedelic look this is the one for you
if not you can easily go full matt black
everything with a skin from our channel
sponsored a brand so if you'd like to
keep it low-key like that i'll drop a
link to those below so huawei like i've
mentioned has sort of taken after
samsung a little bit with their
aesthetic but they've also carved out
some things that are their own some of
them for the better some of them not so
much so the psychedelic a triple color
thing sure that's all you want
on the top and bottom they own that the
shape of the camera bump they sort of
own that too but it's pretty huge this
thing legit wobbles on a table to the
point where it's actually note
possible that could bother some people
the speaker down here at the bottom it's
consistent with other phones and it's
decently loud but doesn't sound great
and it's disappointingly
really easy to accidentally block with a
single finger and there's no earpiece
speaker to balance that out and then the
whole button situation is kind of
interesting so first of all the power
and volume rocker are on the same side
kind of wish they weren't while what
keeps doing this but I wish the volume
rocker was on the other side which is
just blank and then on most phones a
DoubleTap of the power button is your
camera shortcut on this phone dope
tapping the power button doesn't do that
it just sleeps and wakes really fast
it's actually double pressing the volume
down button which gets you into the
camera unless you're on the home screen
in which case double pressing volume
down just lowers your volume so there's
no camera shortcut then holding down the
power button isn't for shutting down
that'll get you to Google assistant so
that accented power button has a long
press it sort of doubles as a voice
assistant trigger and then power and
volume down is still a screen shot power
and volume up starts to screen recording
and then to turn the phone off entirely
you have to hold down the power button
don't say anything to Google assistant
and then keep waiting for another 2 or 3
seconds to get the shutdown menu that
pops up over Google assistant so it's
just a little bit of a taste of the
finicky nests of this phone but that's
just the Huawei way it's the well the
Huawei way hardware-wise though if you
like a phone that does check a lot of
boxes this one does it you got your
premium build quality
there's ip68 water resistance there's
expandable storage your high-end specs
it's all there
it also has the earpiece speaker behind
the glass so this whole top third of the
phone is the earpiece and it even tells
you where to put up your ear to listen
to it and it doesn't buzz at all like
LG's did so it sounds great it doesn't
double as a second front facing speaker
though I think some people would trade
it for a real speaker so that you didn't
have such an easily mutable source of
audio but hey that's the Huawei way but
you know what else is behind the glass
is that fingerprint reader it's decent
at best
I found it fine it's optical so it's
another one of those first-generation
fingerprint readers that works about as
well as any other like the one in the
oneplus 60 I actually found it to be
faster than the ultrasonic one in the
Galaxy S ten but I think a lot of the
optical ones are what I do like is that
it's smart about showing you where the
reader is as soon as you pick up the
phone
you can quickly unlock it while the
screen is off and it's pretty good about
that but it still has to shine that
annoyingly bright light so in screen
fingerprint readers are still in the
early stages of actually getting good
anyway the display is a good one too
it's very bright and very high
resolution looks great for videos and
games it's not the brightest but it is
definitely viewable outdoors I might be
starting to get over the sort of
bleeding over the edge thing that
they've done with this phone and Samsung
has done a little bit I'm kind of torn
on it because they get a little extra
glare on the sides but it still looks
really cool but it definitely hasn't
been anywhere near stopping me from
using the phone and liking it I just
think I actually wouldn't mind if it was
flat the screen is so nice anyway and
then sadly no headphone jack in this
phone our IP sorry headphone jack fans
the p30 does have one that p30 pro does
not same thing as last year that's about
the only box this phone doesn't check
that along with stereo speakers and the
performance is all around
excellent so it's super responsive and
fast and thanks to the ki-rin 980 and
eight gigs of ram I've had no slowdowns
or any questionable lag or anything with
the p30 Pro which is awesome it's one of
my favorite things about this phone and
it actually goes hand-in-hand with the
incredible battery life I didn't even
mention the battery life this 4200
milliamp hour cell is the new undisputed
heavyweight champ for battery and
smartphones period I mean I'm ending
days with 4045 percent left I'm getting
seven plus hours of screen on time on
heavy days I don't even worry about when
I charged anymore I just plug it in
whenever I feel like it this is the
champ this is what you want you want to
never have to worry about the battery
when you're using your phone if you're a
heavy user or someone who travels a lot
that's awesome for the peace of mind and
honestly if you're a light user this is
a 2-day phone comfortably for real two
full days of use a lot of people have
mentioned Huawei phones are notoriously
very aggressive with killing background
apps to extend battery which is pretty
true but I feel like they can get away
with it in my case because it reopens
apps so fast so I give a big thumbs up
here to performance and to battery life
so the big dark rose for me right now
with Huawei phones and it always has
been is their software so this guy's
running there emu eye skin on top of
android pi just some people like it some
people don't and I'm in that second camp
but there's a ton of great features I
love the dark mode so if you go under
battery settings there's
toggle to darken interface colors and it
permeates throughout the whole OS so
it's easy on the eyes dark mode is
basically everywhere I also like that in
any app you can swipe across the
navigation bar to enter one handed mode
and this is a gesture that you can do
with one hand and it makes it easier to
type or just scroll or reach things in
the corners it's kind of like apples
reach ability but I think a better
easier gesture but there's also things I
just don't like so the Settings app is
still a clutter it's hard to navigate
and I wish they'd organize it a little
bit better or clean it up then there's
all the Huawei bloat there's
pre-installed apps when I'm pinching to
zoom it triggers Huawei's high-touch a
service that I just don't ever want to
use so you got a disable things like
that another thing if you have multiple
notifications in most other versions of
Android I'm used to you can expand the
notification to open one instance of it
or tap the whole notification group to
open that app but on this phone you
can't do that tap to just open the app
so it expands them every time requiring
an extra tap for me to open that annoyed
me and on small details like zooming in
with the camera app strangely takes two
hands because of where they put the zoom
slider at the bottom when pretty much
every other phone is put careful
attention into making sure I can zoom
with one hand then there's just always
been this constant weird bug where
sometimes I press the home button to go
home and it just doesn't go home it
doesn't respond I think that's like a
pretty basic thing it should be able to
do every time this happens every day
multiple times per day for me it's hard
for me to get on board with that
so this one is propped up and held back
by the software at the same time like
it's definitely not that they don't have
enough features or customization there's
plenty it's just that it feels like the
user experience isn't the main focus
when designing all this stuff like
Samsung had the same problem they
redesigned all their stuff one UI is now
pretty great so I'd say wow way is due
for that same update so all that brings
us to the main head turning feature the
reason you're all here the reason you
may have heard about this phone in the
first place and that's these cameras
there are four sensors on the back but
really three cameras the main sensor the
ultra wide the periscope zoom and then
there's a fourth time of flight sensor
that helps with depth measurement so the
two main features that are really
catching eyes about the p30 pros cameras
and rightfully so are the zoom range and
the low-light performance
so the zoom range I kind of feel is
super borderline between useful feature
and gimmick so the periscope zoom which
actually has a fascinating physical
structure as shown by the jerry-rigged
everything teardown it will do a 5x
optical zoom and then you can keep going
to 10x which will sharpen and use AI and
combining with the main sensor to try to
be lossless but I found it's already
starting to get softer and then you can
keep going 20 X 30 X 40 X all the way up
to 50 times which is kind of ridiculous
where most smartphones will go maybe 8 X
2 10 X zoom tops so like yes it does
actually work and it has generally
pretty impressive results but most of
the time do people really actually zoom
in that much like here's how far 50
times really is it's absurd like how
many photos do you really take like that
are you a spy is this really super creep
mode it's funny there was so much
attention on it that I actually found
myself like knowing I had this feature
taking tons of zoomed in photos much
more often than I usually do even though
I've had a telephoto camera in
smartphones before but I think I topped
out at around 10x zoom before it stopped
being crisp and useful and started being
soft and gimmicky still funny though I
definitely found that the ultra wide was
way more useful for when you're close to
large subjects or you want to change up
the perspective a bit or do a bigger
landscape shot it does a great job of
minimizing than getting and Distortion I
use this more often than I actually ever
went past 10x zoom but then the night
mode the night mode is the real
game-changer here which was way more
useful and impressive to me so go into
any dark environment first of all go out
at night or in a dark room or a dimly
lit and being a restaurant anything like
that the viewfinder right off the bat is
showing more than most and then you snap
the photo and let it process for a quick
second and boom it's showing the scene
with way more light than real life
usually showing more than the actual
human eye is seeing so I did a couple
comparisons myself with the iPhone 10s
which doesn't have a night mode versus
the pixel threes night sight which has
been pretty much class-leading by a long
shot
up until this month and then versus the
p30 Pro literally in auto mode and the
results were absolutely sick
so the
our yyb debayer and image processing are
clearly making a really big difference
here images from the p30 Pro in
literally basically pitch-black look
like you're shining a light into your
scene it's wild and it's actually kind
of addicting and fun to play with the
only downside is the fact that it does
this in auto mode all the time which
means sometimes you're dimly lit bar
shots will actually look too bright you
know it's funny during huawei's
presentation of this phone they showed
pretty much exclusively like nighttime
and low-light shots especially when
comparing to the competition to the
point where they pretty much didn't even
talk about daylight photography at all
not that they're bad in daylight of
course the May 20 Pro just won the blind
smartphone camera test but it's just
kind of funny they're so dialed in with
low light that they almost don't even
talk about daylight stuff but I think
that's actually a pretty good idea
that's where most people take a lot of
photos I will say daytime photos from
the p30 Pro fell in line with what we
saw from the mate 20 Pro they're coming
down from their hyper over-processed
sharpened land into a more toned-down
realistic look for sure it still loves
to overexpose but that can be fixed and
the 40 megapixel sensor down sampling to
10 megapixel photos still turns out
plenty details I feel like I can still
identify Huawei colorscience though on
site because especially with the Reds
it's a little bit behind the rest
compare it like this shot for example
with the skin tones on the pixel versus
the p30 Pro it consistently has this
sort of magenta cast on skin that's
actually hard to edit out so with that
in mind if we're talking about overall
image quality the p30 Pro still not
quite the best and we've had this
conversation plenty of times now oh is
this the new best smartphone camera in a
lot of ways it is but in some ways it
isn't turns out the best smartphone
camera is a little more nuanced than
that there is more than one best
smartphone camera and that's not a
cop-out that's just true if you just
want the absolute best image quality and
nothing else then the best smartphone
camera that person is the pixel 3 it
still is it has the best color science
especially and on there's dynamic range
and detail and white balance but that's
in an ageing phone that's starting to
get kind of slow and
also not multiple cameras so if you take
a lot of low-light shots and you want
the best fastest low-light camera the
best smartphone camera for that person
is the p30 Pro if you want the most
versatile smartphone camera the best
smartphone camera is the p30 Pro but if
you want the best video camera in any
smartphone the best smartphone camera is
the iPhone 10s bayamón so you got to
know what you want in a smartphone
camera that'll determine what's the best
for you
p30 Pro is awesome it's probably the
best right now for most people but if
you happen to be someone who wants to
take a lot of video that's an area where
this falls short date/time photography
you're gonna get better
image quality out of the pixel camera so
those things are worth knowing about and
that whole summary kind of works for the
p30 pro as a whole phone - you got to
know what you want if you want a phone
that has an amazing battery life and
then checks pretty much all the boxes
you don't worry too much about speaker
quality this is an awesome phone if you
want a great fast camera you take a lot
of low-light shots like a lot of people
do this is gonna be really impressive
but yeah that's that's what you got in
out this is a great phone so if you're
cool with buying a huawei phone in 2019
with that huge asterisk and you know
about it then uh is a great step up
until the next one thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace